in a memo the outside council hired to
question Christine bossy Ford argues no
reasonable prosecutor would bring
criminal charges based on her testimony
Rachel Mitchell lists nine apparent
weaknesses citing inconsistencies in
Blasi Ford's inability to remember key
details like how she got home Mitchell
said the testimony lacks witness
cooperation and evidence she also writes
the activities of congressional
Democrats a likely affected dr. Ford's
account Democrats have argued that
Kavanagh is interviewing for a job and
the witness was not on trial the delay
in Brett Kavanaugh is confirmation could
force President Trump to push back a
meeting with Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein for another week President
called the meeting after Rosen Stein
reportedly suggested recording the
president in a seek in secret and
discussed whether mr. Trump could be
removed under the 25th amendment
Rosenstein denies that happened if he's
forced out that could affect special
counsel Robert Muller's probe of Russian
interference in the 2016 election that
investigation which Rosenstein oversees
is the focus of Greg Miller's new book
The Apprentice Trump Russia and the
subversion of American democracy Miller
is national security correspondent for
the Washington Post part of a team that
won the Pulitzer Prize this year for
reporting on the Russia probe good
morning good morning John thanks what's
gonna happen to residence time so huge
question really with big implications it
would think it would be hard politically
to fire Rosenstein ahead of the
elections in part because you know
you'll end up looking like again you're
impeding an investigation which is what
the Republicans are up against even in
the Cavanaugh hearings right now how far
are they willing to let the FBI go to do
its work there how can you do that twice
from leading up to the election it seems
dangerous but then it's Trump you never
know he could be out with a tweet you
know before we even know it but you
write about Rosen's I knee is a very
low-key guy he never wanted to be front
and center and he became front and
center because of the president and in a
way he got back at the president you say
right I mean he's not a guy who seems to
like the spotlight very much but he has
taken it at key moments in this whole
saga so you know the White House when
Trump decides he's going to fire Comey
they hang that too
decision on rod Rosenstein they have him
write a memo explain the rationale
Rosenstein somehow is just caught off
guard doesn't see that coming when he
submits that memo he doesn't see how
he's being set up and he you know that
animates him and angers him motivates
him he's the one then who then sort of
secretly hiding this all a while from
the White House even from Jeff Sessions
decides to appoint a special counsel and
decides on Bob Muller to leader you do
such terrific reporting throughout this
book and one of the things we picked up
on was that former director of the CIA
Michael Morell talks about the Russian
influence in the 2016 election he calls
it the political equivalent of 9/11 yeah
the question has always been about
collusion or coordination with the Trump
campaign what have you found the Bob
Muller perhaps is zeroing in on well Bob
Muller has a lot that we don't mean he
has kept such a close hold on where his
investigations going that but the but
the many indictments that we've seen so
far lead give us a lot of clues
obviously he's very very focused on the
obstruction front and his interest in
the these figures around Trump including
Trump's fixer and lawyer are ways to get
at that question and his deal with
metaphor take him much closer to
figuring out is there collusion is there
a deal what do we know about Trump's
finances given his business interests
his finances have always been sort of
really opaque but the closer you look at
them the more troubling they can seem
right there is a lot of a lot of money
coming from unknown sources a lot of
weird changes in direction and his
financial empire over the year including
going from somebody who believed in
borrowing heavily for everything he did
to suddenly paying cash for everything
with no real clear sense for where all
that money came from Greg people have
always looked at the tax returns be in
part because of the role they played in
the campaign is that is the kind of
rosetta stone to understand all of this
is that your view does Muller have a
half of those tax returns I weed that's
a huge question I
imagine he does we don't know for sure
but he can get tax returns pretty easily
I think he has a lot more than tax
returns I mean he is dealing with
Trump's basically his CFO now and
getting lots of information you write
about the similarities between Trump and
mr. Muller which I thought were
surprising some superficial similarities
but you say but there are really key
differences in their leadership styles
yeah I mean when you look back at their
backgrounds it's you just couldn't find
two more contrasting individuals and I
thought this was fascinating and spent a
great deal of time in the book talking
about it because Trump was known as a
bully from the very beginning from his
grade school days liked picking on
people liked making people uncomfortable
liked even picking on teachers and
making them uncomfortable Muller head of
the tanning booth is up a tanning booth
in his dorm room and he's just doing
crazy stuff Muller is is has this code
that emerges very early on in his life
and there's a scene in the book where I
write about somebody in his he's at a
lunch in his prep school somebody's
getting picked on who's not in there to
defend themselves and he cuts off the
conversation and walks out of the room
he won't stand for that kind of behavior
and you just sort of see this violent
conflict and clash of ideas and
approaches to life and codes between
Muller and Trump trumpet a draft dodger
didn't go to Vietnam and how many tools
did Bob Muller do Muller does I believe
one tour but it's a pretty eventful one
yeah I mean he's you did he's given
these multiple awards he enlists because
one of his upperclassmen at Princeton
has is enlisted ahead of him yep Craig
Miller it's a fascinating book thank you
and incredible reporting thank you the
titles interesting - we should just note
also that we did reach out to the White
House about your book we didn't hear
back from them but we always check with
both sides here